la publicité sur les préservatifs
prochainement autorisé en France c'est
une des mesures que le ministre de la
Santé Michel Barzac a fait adopté hier
au cours du Conseil cela devrait
permettre en particulier de freiner la
progression inquiétante du sida l'un des
grands spécialistes de cette maladie le
professeur montagier vient de lancer un
cri d'alarme dans le journal Le Monde il
estime que nous ne consacrons pas assez
d'argent en France à la lutte contre ce
fléau et que nos chercheurs vont prendre
du retard quel rôle peuvent jouer les
préservatif dans ce combat Jean-Pierre
quinçon sur le bandeau d'un coureur
cycliste en évitant toute allusion au
produit voici où pouvait se situer par
exemple jusqu'à maintenant la publicité
concernant les préservatifs un marché
qui aurait pourtant besoin de promotion
en France actuellement 6 %
d'utilisateurs contre 35 % en
Grande-Bretagne et 70 % au Japon mais si
le ministre de la Santé a proposer d'en
libéraliser la publicité c'est surtout
parce que les préservatifs peuvent
prévenir le sida a été démontré en
laboratoire et ça a été démontré par des
études épidémiologiques où on a pu
observer ce qui se passait chez des gens
qui ont utilisé ce préservatif toutes
les situations à risque doivent
aujourd'hui imposer l'utilisation de
préservatif que vous entendez par
situation à risque c'est situations à
risque c'est situations où les relations
se passent dans de manière
anonyme avec des gens que l'on ne
connaît pas ou et Don on ne connaît pas
le l'état de santé utilisation large des
préservatifs aux États-Unis a été l'une
des mesures qui a été développé pour la
prévention du sida le préservatif est
également un moyen efficace de
prévention d'autres maladies
sexuellement transmissible par exemple
les infections à clamidier responsable
chaque année de plus de 10000 cas de
stérilité en France reste à convaincre
les utilisateurs la parole sera bientôt
au publicitaires